ينضم إلي الآن وزير الخارجية
أنطوني بلينكن مرحباً السيد الوزير
شكرا جزيلاً لأن أكون معكم ،
يقول الرئيس بايدن إنه يعتقد الآن
أن هناك وقف إطلاق نار
أه بين الإسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين هناك فرصة كبيرة
أه لمزيد من الإيجابية
التطورات أو الفرص الحقيقية
أعتقد أنه إذا كنت أقتبس منه بشكل
صحيح وأتساءل هل هناك حقًا أعني
أن لديك حكومة إسرائيلية
تبدو
صلبة جدًا لديك سلطة فلسطينية
يقودها رجل يبلغ من العمر 85 عامًا
لا تعرفه  خائف جدًا من إجراء
الانتخابات خوفًا مما سيحدث
يتحكم حماس في غزة ،
هل هناك حقًا احتمال لحدوث
نوع من التحرك نحو حل سياسي حقيقي
فريدا أعتقد أنه يجب أن يكون هناك شيء أعتقد أنه
يتم تذكير كلا الجانبين بأنه يتعين علينا إيجاد  طريقة
لكسر هذه الحلقة لأننا إذا لم نفعل
ذلك فسوف يكرر نفسه
بتكلفة كبيرة ومعاناة إنسانية كبيرة
من جميع الجوانب ، يبدو أننا عملنا
بجد مع هذا المكثف ولكن
الدبلوماسية وراء الكواليس للوصول إلى
وقف إطلاق
النار وأعتقد أن الرئيس بايدن الذي يقود هذا
الجهد
أصدر حكمًا بأننا يمكن أن نكون أكثر
فاعلية
في القيام بذلك وفي النهاية
بعد أه هذا الجهد المكثف
عبر الحكومة
أه وصلنا إلى حيث يريد الجميع أن
يكون  الذي كان لإنهاء العنف ولكن الآن
كما قال الرئيس
أعتقد أنه من واجبنا جميعًا أه
محاولة جعل الدور
أه للبدء في بناء شيء أكثر
إيجابية وما يعنيه ذلك
في القلب هو أن أه الفلسطينيين
والإسرائيليين على حد
سواء  أعرف في حياتهم اليومية في
حياتهم اليومية مقاييس متساوية
لأه فرصة لأمن الكرامة
شيء لمسته أه في
مقالتك في منشور واشنطن هذا الأسبوع
قال رئيس إدارة بايدن
عندما كان يقوم بحملته الانتخابية
بمجرد أن  أصبحنا رئيسًا
سنعود للانضمام إلى الاتفاق النووي الإيراني قال الإيرانيون
نفس الشيء
نحن الآن بعد أربعة أشهر من
الإدارة
لم يحدث شيء أه كلا الجانبين  قال
إنه يبدو أن هناك
شيئًا من المواجهة وأن إيران لئيمة
بينما تنشغل بإثراء الشيء ذاته الذي
حذر منه الناس مثلك عندما
كان هذا هو
الفشل الدبلوماسي ، ما كان ينبغي يا رفاق أن تكونوا
قادرين على ذلك
العودة للصفقة في غضون أسبوع
أو
شيئين اقرأ أولاً أعتقد أن الخطوات
التي تتخذها إيران أه
أه تؤكد على إلحاح محاولة
إعادة إيران للامتثال
لالتزاماتها بموجب الاتفاق النووي
الصفقة التي أوقفت
أه أه  الجوانب الخطيرة
للبرنامج النووي احتمالية أن
يكون لديهم
مواد انشطارية لسلاح نووي في
وقت قصير أمم لدينا
أه أعتقد أن خمس جولات من المحادثات
الآن لمحادثات الآن غير مباشرة
أه في فيينا وفي الحقيقة فريقنا
يعود إلى  فيينا في الأيام
القادمة لمتابعة ذلك أعتقد أننا قد
أحرزنا تقدمًا بالفعل في توضيح ما أه
ما يجب على كل جانب فعله للعودة
إلى الامتثال الكامل
للسؤال المعلق السؤال المعلق  أنه ليس لدينا
إجابة
حتى الآن هو ما إذا كانت إيران في نهاية
اليوم مستعدة لفعل ما هو ضروري
للعودة إلى الامتثال
للاتفاقية ، هذا هو الاقتراح الذي أه
نختبره ولكنني أفكر فيه.  هذه
الجولات من المناقشات
والمحادثات أوضح وأوضح ما يجب
أن
يحدث والسؤال هو أن إيران مستعدة للقيام
بذلك